if you've heard at lindsay lohan speak
in an interview lately you might have
noticed she doesn't sound like she used
to this is just me holding it with me
walking going whereas the paparazzi
maybe across the street I didn't know
and they crucified me for it in America
they made me seem like Satan reference
here's how Lindsey spoke 1et last caught
up with her in 2013 how much fun was it
to make the movie it was really fun he's
a really nice guy and I said it the
other night on on David Letterman I
really appreciate how he's so good with
his crew and I think that means a lot to
me and it always has yeah definitely
different and a lot of fans are confused
by the change but Lynn's has explained
it to the Daily Mail saying she's just
studying so many languages right now
that her speech pattern has changed
Leeloo says she's fluent in English and
French can understand Russian and is
learning Turkish Italian and Arabic so
what's interesting though is that the
new accent isn't always there here's
Lindsey on snapchat just this week yeah